[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami les nounours tu es
bien agitée ce soir c'est parce que je
suis du clavier parle pas trop bon les
châles et reportons le jt monde
à l'eau sur la terre je sais bien
profond de bord les petits ronds
[Musique]
évidemment il a oublié une botte
et juliette à elle apporté son beau
chapeau au soir la compagnie bonsoir
manges tu sais le pan nombreuses la
compagnie et oui cornichons et juliette
has hors pack et je vois que c'était
pour 10 de cornichons à oublier une
porte qui est à oublier son chapeau
sur les larves veillait au oui c'est une
bonne idée faisons leur impôt pas quels
ils vont être contents
[Musique]
voilà une boîte nours et aja les revend
merci nicolas
la chine est potes
le chapeau
c'est parfait je vais poster ce soir le
paquet à rex prêche comme ça ils auront
demain wata ne ferme pas là je dépose
deux baisers dans le paquet pour teint
et chant
et pour juliette à
[Musique]
un salut pour dada ce qui raconta à huy
et voilà vous aussi vous devez être
content je veux vous voir tes en avant
la musique et la danse
moi je vais danger aujourd'hui avec les
petits
on
[Musique]
ne peut pas tromper prenons la main mais
surtout tenez vous bien
d'abord on va tourner à la de se voter
mais gentiment sans bousculade
puis on va s'arrêter à dire de l'autre
côté on fait une de promenade
en pyjama et jeunes amis damoisy c'est
ça vous plaît tant mes enfants venez pas
ici un petit tour par 6 jeux vous
devriez ces résines ou pâte dans
chantons de pourcentage
en avant les bons danseurs
aulus le pro dans son lit
manning
nuit les petits
la
j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
ni nicolas d'or bien petite soeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
patron vous stopper deux minutes au
dessus du bureau de poste le plus proche
s'il vous plaît j'ai un colis urgents a
expédié d'accord nounours bonne nuit les
enfants allez vite vous coucher
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette et
de bien vous laver les dents est fait
pour
[Musique]
oh